Hello, everybody.
(gross mouth noises)
(and Mark's like "what the fuck was that sound I just made??")
My name is Markiplier...
and welcome back...
to the World's...
(more gross noises)
(trying not to laugh) Quietest...
Let's Play.
My mic...
is at its...
most...
sensitive...
set-ting.
I have to be...
exceptionally quiet this time.
It's currently...
5:58 A.M....
and my stepmom... who's visiting...
is in the other room.
So...
it's time...
once again...
to play...
quietly.
Oh.
I'm sure...
that... whatever the hell...
is over that... blind ledge...
is going to be both...
fun...
and educational...
for my guy here.
Oh, God.
I don't think my character...
has any more bones to break.
And here...
you can see the face...
of imminent... regret.
Here...
the spine has erupted into shattered pieces;
the pelvis, exploded into various meaty bits.
I know...
that as a cool, happenin' dude,
I think I can s-
I think I can still survive this one.
There's a po-
(tries to speak)
Uh-
Thank you for returning my skateboard to me.
Oh, my good friend, the Boogie Bus.
Please-
ow.
Boogie Bu-
(quietly giggles)
The Boogie Bus...
betrayed me...
before I was even doomed.
Please...
You don't have to do this.
No!
I'm sorry-
(stifled giggles)
You got what you deserved...
you bus bi-
(softly laughing) Oh, fuck you.
(not even trying to stay quiet while laughing)
The Boogie Bus came back for revenge.
Ah, yes.
The sweet serenity...
of a phallic-shaped... rocket.
This level is called...
Kerbal...
Dismount...
Program...
and I'm certain...
I hate everything you stand for.
We need...
to ascEEEEEENNNNND...!
Oh.
(laughing) Goodbye, car.
What we need now...
is... boosting?
Maybe?
Question mark?
We've done it.
We've made it.
Is this space?
Are we in space?
(pleasured inhale)
Oh.
No, wait...
Lemme...
uh-
Yeah, I was wrong.
Where's my car?
(very softly laughing) I know where it went.
If we wait...
Oh-so-patiently...
(boop)
There he is-
(laughing softly)
I don't know why that was really funny to me.
(getting spoopy) Hello, darkness, my old friend.
It's good to see you here again.
Turbo... Dismount...
has been so...
lonely...
without you.
And you'll always be...
with me.
M̧̢̢̕͢è̴҉̢̛e̴̴͢e̴̢̡͘e̡̢ȩ̵̨e̷̷͟͝e̡͟͝͠.
And here...
we see the elegant...
Ballerina Train...
preparing for her...
big debut.
What a-
(giggling)
What a beautiful-
(laughing as he gives up completely on staying quiet)
You guys don't know what I'm laughing at...
(laughing) Probably...
But-
Hang on, let me set the scene for you.
Now you tell me...
if this... doesn't look like a dick,
(laughing) suddenly popping out of the tunnel...
and then being slapped...
(tappa-tappa-tappa-tappa)
(tappa)
repeatedly.
(giggles softly)
(laughing loudly again)
Okay...
Okay.
Alright.
I'm glad to know that my... level of maturity...
has i-if anything, DEcreased... over the years...
since the last time I played... Turbo Dismount.
Thank you guys so much for watching...
another World's... Quietest Let's Play.
And as always...
I will see you...
in the next video.
Bye-byeeee!